[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
promouvoir les films des autres voyez
par exemple on souvent on s'identifie un
critique on y tient j'aime je suis
souvent assez d'accord avec secrétique
là alors on serait d'accord avec les le
goût de certains acteurs et ça serait
plus facile de vendre un film dans
lequel on n'est pas si on était obligé
de dire oui c'était formidable ton âge
était merveilleux je me suis vraiment
entendu
c'est pas toujours on finit par avoir
l'impression que ça sonne faux et c'est
un peu agaçant tandis que si c'était
pour vanter le travail d'une autre
comédienne ou d'un ça serait possible
qu'ils vont venir ce soir on pourrait
inventer leur travail
vous dites quand on compose 10 heures
par jour sur un plateau c'est difficile
après de continuer à composer j'ai
tourné toute la journée et c'est
difficile de j'ai pas envie d'être j'ai
envie d'être moi-même et parfois on
n'est pas fatalement je vais oui
[Musique]
alors le 21 février Nathalie Baye sort
un film qui s'appelle Barni et ses
petites contrariétés avec Fabrice
Luchini marie Gillain et vous réalisez
par Bruno Chiche alors le pitch je le
fais volontiers
parce qu'il est très bon donc ces Barney
c'est Luchini qui joue le rôle alors
Barni ça vient de Bernard et Barnabé
parce que son père voulait qu'il
s'appelle Bernard et sa mère Bernadet
donc finalement il s'est appelé Barni
alors il a une femme c'est vous il a une
maîtresse c'est Marie Gillain et il a un
amant c'est Hugo spire c'est à dire le
mec déjà si tu veux il est tranquille en
plus il y avait un qui habite en France
en Angleterre etc et alors un jour il
reçoit un cadeau de sa maîtresse et de
son amant il reçoit un cadeau un billet
de train dans l'Orient-Express pour
aller passer un week-end en amoureux le
1er mai à Venise
alors très content mais son épouse
compte lui offrir le même cadeau ça fait
trois weekends à Venise le 1er mai avec
sa femme son amant et sa maîtresse quand
il réalise il renvoie les billets à son
amant et à sa maîtresse mais secondes
adresse voilà alors après bon on va pas
continuer voilà après ça se complique
mais c'est très bien ça un vrai c'est
votre village quoi c'est vraiment un
scénario un peu la fedo quoi c'est votre
ville moderne quoi
il est incroyable péripéties
c'est un comique de situation et moi je
trouve que c'est une comédie qui est
très bien écrite avec des vrais
personnages et des situations qui sont
vraiment drôles et amusantes à
brinoshish j'avais fait un court-métrage
avec lui il y a 10 ans
et oui il a fait pas mal de films
publicitaires et je suis contente qu'il
ait fait ce premier long-métrage alors à
part ça vous travaillez toute la journée
sur nouveau film de haguillon Gabriel
c'est quoi c'est l'adaptation française
de atfal qui est une expliqué aux gens
parce que tout le monde connaît pas la
série anglaise qui s'appelle absolument
fabuleux qui est complètement délirante
avec deux femmes interprétées par
Josiane Balasko et moi qui sont deux
deux femmes qui font tout ce qu'il faut
pas faire c'est-à-dire qu'elles sont
alcooliques drogués il y en a une qui
était une mauvaise mère passer deux deux
deux dingues de d'hystérique et c'est un
c'est un film assez audacieux drôle
j'espère et voilà je crois que vous avez
deux heures de maquillage et de
démaquillage par jour transformé
physiquement mon père est venu l'autre
jour sur le plateau il m'a pas reconnu
bon voilà j'ai une espèce de chignon
énorme blonde un maquillage outrancier
et il y a beaucoup beaucoup de travail
donc Nathalie Baye on va parler de votre
vie vous avez un frère une scolarité pas
terrible pas terrible vous étiez quand
vous étiez petites paresseuse et
dyslexique vous êtes plus dyslexique les
plus paraisseuses si mon fameux dyslexie
maintenant c'est je suis pas dyslexique
dans mon travail et quand je joue quand
je suis dans les mots des autres ça va
et paresseuse
non parce que j'aime ce que je fais
j'étais paresseuse parce que j'aimais
pas l'école quoi j'ai une enfance
vos parents étaient peintres donc il y a
pas toujours de l'argent à la maison des
fois il n'avait puis des fois il n'avait
pas il avait plus souvent des jours où
il y en avait pas
et vous comprenez très jeune ça vous a
aidé parce que vous comprenez très jeune
grâce à vos parents que l'argent dans la
vie c'est pas un but essentiel
ça apporte une liberté assez grande et
puis on connaît tous pas mal de
personnes qui ont de l'argent et qui
sont pas
particulièrement mieux que les autres
c'est plus confortable bien sûr et pas
en avoir c'est infernal mais le trop
l'avidité et la recherche de l'argent
absolument
alors en plus ça vous amène à pas
accepter n'importe quoi pour soutenir en
train de vie c'est à dire que plutôt que
de tourner les navets vous préférez pas
tourner oui parce que j'ai toujours eu
le sentiment que la liberté pas le plus
grand luxe c'était la liberté et c'était
de faire des choses qu'on avait envie de
faire donc pour moi c'est le sale plus
grand Luc c'est pas de posséder des
tonnes de choses mais c'est ça c'est de
dire tiens j'ai pas envie de faire ce
film et je vais faire celui-ci mais ça
c'était aussi déjà un certain confort
alors vous avez quitté l'école à l'âge
de 14 ans et vous orienter d'abord vers
la vers la danse
et c'est une durée école parce que vous
dites j'ai pas eu un compliment pendant
10 ans et ça m'a appris à jamais croire
que c'était arrivé c'est-à-dire c'est
quand même une école très très dure quoi
la danse je crois que c'est ce plus
difficile la danse classique c'est ce
qui a plus difficile et de plus je sais
pas s'il y a quelque chose de
douloureux même
l'âge de 15 ans fait 8 heures de danse
par jour chez une Russe donc finalement
ça a été un coup de peau pour vous la
danse parce que ça vous a vous étiez un
peu paresseuse et ça vous a obligé quand
même une certaine rigueur
heureuse mais c'était mieux que l'école
et ça m'a appris effectivement la
discipline vous avez dit après ça même
tourner avec qu'elle a c'est de la
rigolade mais c'est vrai vous visiez
très haut toujours c'est à dire que
rapidement vous avez voulu aller danser
avec des grandes compagnies américaines
non non c'est pas je visais pas très
haut c'est que bon c'est des histoires
vous savez c'est des contextes dans la
famille et des trucs des parents qui
vont plus la famille qui se disloquent
un petit peu comme ça et j'ai eu la
chance et l'opportunité de partir aux
États-Unis j'étais baby-sitter dans une
famille je suis restée une année et je
continue mes études de danse puis après
j'ai fait partie de petites tournées
là-bas j'avais pas mes papiers je suis
revenu en France voilà et vous revenez
en France vous avez pas de carte de
travail et vous repartez jamais parce
qu'un jour avec une copine je vais dans
un cours d'art dramatique et j'ai
commencé à découvrir le plaisir de jouer
et de et voilà c'est la déprime en plus
un jour de déprime parce que vous ayez
tourné dans les autocars c'est horrible
c'est vraiment la zone les hôtels de
province tout ça et un jour vous allez
voir à quoi ça ressemble et vous sur
René Simon qui vous qui vous comme ça
qui flash sur vous quoi
il vous dit tu es fait pour ça
j'ai fait pour ça ne paye pas tes cours
mais met la gomme je te présenterai au
Conservatoire un coup de bolet énorme
oui
donc dans les débuts des 70 au
Conservatoire avec
Uster du soulier Villeret Balmer Francis
Perrin et vous décrochez le deuxième
prix de comédie
classique comédie moderne théâtre
étrangers et c'était c'était une belle
aventure à l'époque c'est extraordinaire
avec vous parce que ça moi ça me fascine
c'est qu'à l'époque Paul Morand qui
était encore en vie cherche sa femme
était devenue aveugle et il cherche une
lectrice pour sa femme il écrit au
conservatoire et vous êtes désigné pour
aller lire des livres des journaux des
du courrier à Madame Morand 2 années
c'est incroyable il vous a dragué pour
le moment un petit peu
il était disant draguer non mais il me
faisait du charme
le 28 février on va savoir ce qui s'est
vraiment passé entre Nathalie Bay et pas
le Morand donc à l'époque vous pensez au
théâtre mais pas trop au cinéma parce
que vous dites le cinéma c'est un peu
réservé au havagarmer regard vous avez
votre idéal et vous pensez que vous
n'êtes pas vagarmer et que vous ferez
jamais du cinéma non mais c'est vrai que
quand on est au Conservatoire tout ce
que ce soit Villeret Balmer on pensait
on pensait qu'au théâtre on était des
fous de théâtres et c'était le c'était
vraiment ce qui nous est le plus rêvé et
le premier qui a été engagé au cinéma
c'était du soulier pour une belle fille
comme moi Truffaut et on l'a regardé
comme un comme je sais pas et c'était un
zombie on est en même temps très
admiratif on disait mais qu'est-ce qu'il
va faire il va se fourvoyer au cinéma
c'était vous avez un manager Serge
Rousseau qui vous dit avec ton physique
ça va être difficile sympa mais il va
pas dire ça mais il m'a dit ça va pas
être facile tu sais j'ai pas le physique
classique des jeunes premières à
l'époque c'est vrai que elle était un
peu blonde les yeux bleus
71 Margot cappellier vous conseille à
Robert Wise et là aussi coup de bol
quand même non
ouais c'est à dire que vous jouez tout
people de Robert Wise avec Peter Fonda
c'est rare quand même ça et rechance un
an après Truffaut vous choisit pour
faire la Street dans la nuit américaine
et puis une grande commence on va pas
citer tous les films relancer par Vénus
Beauté institut tout le monde vous a
vous un peu partie du paysage à un
moment et tout le monde vous a
redécouvert avec ce film de Tony
Marshall ça a servi à le bilan aussi
c'est là dessus qu'il a qu'il a fondé sa
carrière et vous ça vous a reboosté
complètement bien alors vous protégez
bien votre fille en tous les cas j'ai
regardé un peu il y a une photo d'elle
en 17 ans et le paparazzi s'est retrouvé
au tribunal
vous êtes c'est pas c'est oui parce que
je pense que les enfants ont besoin
d'avoir une vie tout ce qui est normal
et voilà c'est pour elle aussi avant
tout
on n'expose pas ses enfants comme ça ils
sont pas demandé à avoir des parents
connus donc on avait jamais mais si on
la verra peut-être je sais pas ça dépend
d'elle après bah quand à l'heure à 18
ans
on ne peut compter que sur soi-même
et mettre le poids de son avenir et de
son bonheur sur l'autre c'est pas viable
ah oui je trouve vivre en couple c'est
plus en plus difficile il y a des
moments où on peut être ensemble mais
pas au quotidien je sais pas que je ne
crois pas au couple mais je trouve que
vivre en couple et le quotidien est
quelque chose qui use le le enfin je
sais pas je pense que c'est quelque
chose qui peut user le rapport amoureux
en tous les cas ça j'en suis persuadé et
enfin je sais pas il y a des personnes
qui arrivent à vivre très longtemps en
couple j'ai une grande admiration moi je
suis pas arrivé qu'est-ce qui peut vous
faire flasher chez un homme
moi je pose la question à toutes les
gonzesses maintenant comme ça si tu veux
après j'ai mes fiches qu'est-ce qui me
fait je sais pas et c'était un ensemble
de choses quelqu'un qui vous séduit un
homme qui vous séduit c'est c'est une
présence c'est il y a une intelligence
l'humour
mais vous êtes prêt séduisant c'est pas
les cheveux qui sont
pas c'est un ensemble de choses on peut
pas définir la séduction comme ça en
disant
amoureuse comme ça avant même qu'il est
ouvert la bouche juste en le voyant non
tomber amoureuse non d'être intéressé et
de le trouver séduisant oui mais tomber
amoureuse non vous avez dit votre parfum
préféré chez l'homme c'est l'odeur de la
peau de toute façon je moi je peux pas
supporter de j'aime pas énormément les
parfums et de retrouver une odeur que
j'ai connue sur quelqu'un d'autre je
trouve que lui je trouve que quand
quelqu'un qui est propre une odeur de
peau propre ça inodore particulière où
est tant qu'à faire mais enfin bon je
vois
non mais c'est ce que je trouve le mieux
moi j'aime bien l'odeur de la
je suis beaucoup moins forte que j'en ai
l'air c'est vrai mais j'ai envie de me
montrer solide c'est une forme
d'élégance oui parce que je suis
toujours un petit peu
agacé par souvent de gens qu'on
interview on est tous des gens
privilégiés et les gens qui se plaignent
de leur situation ne leur problème de
leur faites des connus et des problèmes
de ça c'est indécent pour moi c'est
indécent donc la plupart des gens quand
ils vont rencontrer
ça n'a rien de désagréable je sais pas
alors moi je me mets à la place des gens
qui sont là qui nous voient la
télévision et ils disent on est là on
nous aime bien on a et puis on se plaint
non mais c'est pas comme ça
bien
alors maintenant vous savez quand même
qu'on bouge pas par le jingle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est bien
par exemple première question à quoi
vous pensez là
question que vous allez me poser et qui
m'inquiète vous dites quoi le matin
quand vous regardez dans le miroir
rien je suis allée prendre un café et
rien vous dites pas tu es bien tu es
moche
j'ai pas une réflexion
profonde quand vous étiez petit vous lui
ressemblez à qui a une copine de classe
que je trouvais absolument sublimissime
la patience
peut-être l'impatience aussi
qui vous a fait le plus mal
une de mes forces c'est d'oublier les
trucs pas bien quoi j'ai pas envie de
m'encombrer ça alors il y en a
certainement sur le coup qui m'ont fait
du mal mais je m'en fous j'ai oublié et
si vous restez 24 heures à vivre vous
feriez quoi
un grand châtaignier qui est en face de
ma maison dans le centre de la France
avec ma fille
vous êtes toujours cette maison vous
allez souvent là-bas dans la Creuse
c'est ça non
quelle est la dernière personne que vous
ayez envie de tuer
un type qui m'a collé à l'autoroute avec
la voiture et je les trouve que c'était
les mecs qui sont au volant et qui
veulent vous doubler et qui vous collent
comme ça ça c'est le seul moment où je
peux avoir envie de tuer
faut freiner
vous changeriez quoi en vous si vous
aviez une baguette magique
écoutez j'ai mis très très longtemps à
m'accepter alors maintenant ça y est
quoi
si c'était à refaire votre vie qu'est-ce
qu'il y a que vous referiez pas pareil
tout pareil
si on commence à dire des trucs comme ça
on s'en sort pas et
puis les erreurs c'est ce qui vous fait
avancer aussi
qui avez-vous le plus envie de dépasser
moi
j'ai déjà pensé au suicide
quel péché qui vous tente le plus
vous passez pour me faire plaisir non
quand le téléphone sonne vous êtes
heureux ou agacé je sais pas mais dans
notre métier souvent entre 11h et 13h15
c'est infernal et entre 18h et 20h vers
10h après il vous appelle après
8h
vous avez menti pendant cette interview
non
je crois pas voilà merci Nathalie bye
Paris et ses petites contrariétés
ensemble le 21 février avec Nathalie
Baye Fabrice Luchini marie-julin et
Serge à Genève je suis arrivé merci on
va vous envoyer vos couchers vous
tournez demain matin vous tournez tous
les jours j'espère que le film sera bien
bonne soirée merci à vous et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de Inna larditude
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu